fighting on Friday night in southern
Kazakhstan brought this village to a
standstill footage on social media which
cannot be independently verified shows
houses and commercial properties
up in smoke and cars overturned as armed
men embroiled in confrontation throwing
rocks dozens of people were injured and
others killed some would sea urchins
thrashed murmurs it was a terrible night
there was conflict between Kazakhs and
Ingham before
Kazakhs attacked us unexpectedly I think
it was planned the number of victims is
higher the houses on the main streets
are burned all the shops and buildings
are damaged and cars were stolen
if unclear what caused the violence in
the kadai district of jumbled region the
area where the fighting took place is
home to ethnic Kazakhs and the Dungan
minority group muslims of chinese ethnic
origin while Kazakh sounds authorities
declared a state of emergency the
president has called for calm a number
of settlements in the Corti district at
the sambal region clashes and fights
between local residents took place
agitators tried to take advantage of the
situation unfortunately there are dead
and wounded I expressed my sincere
condolences to the families and friends
of the deceased citizens the violence
has forced many people mainly ethnic
dung guns from their homes they're now
trying to cross the border over into
neighboring Kyrgyzstan Muscovado we were
told to leave the area for security
reasons I don't know what's happening
there now we have left everything we
were just told that people from shim
Kenneth will come eight groups in
kyrgyzstan are trying to organize food
and medical assistance for as many
people as they can
who Michigan escapes that all the aid is
coming from different parts everyone is
calling me even from Russia my only
concern is that the aid is only
off-the-book people have organized
themselves we are trying to facilitate
passes at the border I want to thank the
Kyrgyz law enforcement for providing
help to refugees while many here wait
for peace to be restored the Kazakhstan
government says it will set up a
commission of inquiry to address the
underlying cause of the tension for
healing Muhammad's
al Jazeera